When it comes to the vast universe of
SCP, it’s not unusual to happen upon
an entity from time to time that
you aren’t fully acquainted with.
However, SCP-1000 goes by a name
you’re probably more familiar with:
Bigfoot. That’s right, that bigfoot. The
Foundation keeps these creatures under
wraps due to the fact that the simple sight
of them will infect you with a strange disease
that imparts the high probability
of you dropping dead instantly.
Or does it?
The fact is, the Foundation is vastly overstating
the danger of these beasts for secretive reasons:
what we refer to as bigfoots - or is it big
feet? - were actually once a hyper-advanced
nocturnal race that threatened to replace
humanity as the dominant species on earth.
But a deal with a capricious forest
God put humanity back on top,
and reduced SCP-1000 to a
tiny population of mere apes.
The SCP Foundation doesn’t want YOU to
know any of this though, and so they
made up the story about them
having looks that can kill.
The good news for us is that it at least
seems that SCP-1000 doesn’t hold a grudge.